Speaker 1: News continues to be not
so good for Donald Trump's former
election fraud lawyer, so-called Sidney
Powell. Listen to this, Texas state Bar
tells court. Sidney Powell committed
professional misconduct with post-election
lawsuits and could be disbarred. I'm
taking pleasure, I know that, you know,
one of my principles is I don't take pleasure in
the death of others. I don't take it know it's
when people have done really bad things like
the corrosive nature of Sidney Powell, so-called
election fraud lawsuits. She deserves to have
consequences. And we are now learning. Far right
attorney Sidney Powell may soon face disciplinary
action, ranging from a reprimand to disbarment for
her post-election lawsuits alleging widespread
election fraud, as the disciplinary committee at
the State Bar of Texas filed a petition in state
court alleging that she committed professional
misconduct through her efforts to overturn the
election. I love it. There should be consequences,
the only thing is the consequences should go above
Powell. They should get to Trump. They should. I
don't think they will. But consequences are in
order here. Key facts The Commission for Lawyer
Discipline, a committee of the Texas bar, asked
the District Court in Dallas County to issue a
judgment of professional misconduct against Powell
and determine and impose an appropriate sanction.
Can she even work as a lawyer at this point? In
the sense of would anyone even hire her? Like,
I guess there's probably some Trumpists or maybe
people who have absolutely no idea anything about
her who would still hire her, but it seems like
her career is dead in the water anyway from the
self humiliation that she participated in.
The committee alleges Powell violated rules
of professional conduct that prohibit attorneys
from making false statements using false evidence,
bringing frivolous lawsuits. Taking a position
that causes unreasonable delays or burdens.
And engaging in conduct involving dishonesty,
fraud, deceit or misrepresentation. She kind
of did all those things. But what the complaint
points to are her lawsuits in battleground states
alleging fraud. The argument being that she had no
reasonable basis to believe the lawsuits were not
frivolous. I tend to think that that's true. Now
I know that there are lots of people who insist.
Sidney Powell is a true believer. She really
believed all of the stuff the election was
stolen by Joe Biden and affidavits and all
this difference. OK, there's a lot of people.
I think that she plausibly believes there
was some funny business, some funny business,
but I don't think there is any way in hell that
she thought the specific lawsuits she was filing
were actually valid. I just don't. I just don't
think so. Let me know your thoughts. Find me on
Twitter at Packman. And also tomorrow is
a Trump rally in Florence, South Carolina.
If you live in that area and you'd like to be
our correspondent at the rally and you can get
there and you've got, you know, a phone and a
microphone so you can do some interviews for us
will pay you. OK? Info at David Pakman dot
com subject line. Florence. Trump rally.
Let me know if you'd like to go. We're
going to hire someone to be there, and
I would love to hear from you
if you'd like to be that person.
The David Pakman Show is a viewer and listener
supported program, the daily podcast and the
YouTube clips and the radio show and the TV show
and the live streams and the entire thing is
primarily funded by you. You can sign up at join
Packman dot com, get access to the bonus show,
get access to a commercial free audio and video
stream of the show, and get that six hours
before everybody else. Isn't that just the best?
Sign up at Join Packman dot com for instant
access. Let's hear from the most important
people involved with the show. Obviously,
I mean the audience. We take calls via
Discord at David Pakman dot com slash discord